hi lopez the king of
you know the thing knowledge the man
with all the lambos fun to drive up here
in the hollywood hills well now he's out
of those hollywood hills and into crypto
he just launched a coin and i dug into
his project early and oh boy it's rough
i would stay away from this thing with a
six foot pole like you're trying to
social distance from the new
transformers movie but not because i
think tai lopez is a marketing grifter
who will do anything for money no no the
real reason is that his idea is a
derivative clone that reheats other
people's innovations to benefit no one
but himself which makes it a little bit
like his self-help
it all starts with this this is what
we're talking about first today
radio shack radio shack is bringing
cryptocurrency to the mainstream with
defy now if you haven't heard of radio
shack in seven years that's because
they've almost completely collapsed
after failing to adjust to the rise of
the internet and that was sad for many
people because they were nostalgic
memory from the 90s it's even sadder
because they were bought out by these
two tai lopez and his buddy alex mayer
and given that most people associate tai
lopez with get rich quick advertisements
seen at 3am on a youtube rabbit hall
many people struggled to see the
connection between an actual business
and thai but that struggle is now over
since they launched their new coin and
here's their pitch radio shack is a 100
year old brand embedded in the global
consciousness and we're going to lead
the way for blockchain tech to reach
mainstream adoption by other large
brands now this is quite interesting the
brand that is going to lead us into the
future is the one that died because it
failed to grasp it the first time now
how are they going to do that well they
say this how will we make this bridge
radio shack d5 will start with a swap we
believe that this is the lowest hanging
fruit that is full of opportunities our
symbiosis with atlas usv will allow us
to offer the most efficient and
competitive swap on the market now i
know what you're thinking what the hell
is atlas usb and we'll get to that in a
moment but it's important to recognize
all the powerful connections that radio
shack has to offer to make radio shack
crypto a big success according to them
they're partnered with rev
pier one dress barn and steinmart which
if you haven't paid attention recently
all are basically failing businesses
that have nothing to do with crypto but
what they all have in common is actually
that they're all owned and bought by tai
and alex they bought them at low prices
hoping to revitalize them so in essence
these guys are starting a crypto company
partnered with themselves and a bunch of
businesses that failed to adjust to the
modern age irony ladies and gentlemen is
officially dead unless you can explain
to me how dress barn is going to make
you succeed with crypto i'm not exactly
seeing how these uh connect here but now
let's move on to this atlas usv thing
the symbiosis they talked about usv is
an acronym for universal store of value
and it's another crypto token that is
created by drumroll please
ty lopez and his buddy alex mayer which
basically means that tai lopez is
teaming up with tai lopez backed by tai
lopez and i'm sure funded by tai lopez
now it calls itself a community driven
project despite basically being launched
by just two guys but even though that
makes about as much sense as saying
radio shack is going to bring us into
the future i think at least they're
still being consistent with about as
accurate as these claims are but you
know it really gets amazing when you
start looking at their white paper this
could have been an anonymous project and
i would have instantly known that it had
knowledge inside of it why well because
of the quotes bear in mind you have to
understand most white papers or
technical documents describe what they
do what these tokens do like in math
terms right it's mostly just numbers and
economics this has very little of that
very little math and it makes up for
that in famous people quotes from books
tai has read now there's no way to
convey this to you without actually just
telling you about all the stuff he uh
jam-packed into this white paper so i'm
just gonna go through all of them with
you first he quoted renowned
evolutionary psychologist dr david buss
he then quoted mathematician john forbes
nash then they talked about the
aristotelian mean they then quoted
charlie mungers saying beware of
perverse incentives they then go through
robert trevor's evolutionary uh theory
on reciprocal altruism they then talk
about charles darwin saying the sight of
the peacock gives me nightmares which i
can certainly see how that's relevant to
crypto then they say as freud wrote
suffering comes from three quarters they
then say like the aesop fables all find
themselves to be both the lion and the
mouse by the way we're still talking
about a crypto coin here uh then they
talk about adam smith they then quote
the bible only to follow it up with
richard dawkins they quote warren
buffett and then they quote charles
mckay to top it all off now look it's
awesome that you know who these guys are
it's great it's great that you've read
books but unfortunately reading a bunch
of books and knowing a bunch of quotes
is kind of irrelevant to a technical
paper about a token to just fill it with
so many quotes about charles darwin and
the peacock i mean quite frankly i
failed to see the connection but am i
saying that they just filled this thing
with a lot of quotes to avoid having to
do actual math no of course not don't be
so cynical what i am saying though is
that i agree with token sniffer which is
an automated audit and they said that
this thing gets about a 20 out of 100 on
their uh what they call a smell test and
according to them there is a high risk
of this type of token being a scam now
or in the future but i also think it's
pretty funny that after all this talk
about their theories nash equilibriums
and charles darwinian ideas about what
makes the ideal token the contract for
this token is actually
completely similar to a bunch of other
projects take for instance this coin
right here which was done 21 days before
their coin the difference between these
two contracts is literally three lines
of code most of which are just changing
the name on the contract that's right
guys this idea isn't new at all it's
been done by tons of projects before and
repackaged with a lot of uh fancy
language to make it look like it's just
tai lopez's idea and maybe he can get
the money this time in fact it's so
similar to so many other coins that i'm
starting to think that the real quote
tai lopez has learned from is actually
from pablo picasso good artist copy con
artist steel